nach dem hygiene konzeptes die liga
vorgelegt hat denke ich schon dass es
eine gute chance gibt dass wir
geisterspiele wagen können
deswegen wäre denkbar dass wir
vielleicht vielleicht frühestens ab 99
worden
überlegen dann ist solche geister runde
zu spielen wichtig ist für mich normal
dass auch das robert koch institut und
bundesgesundheitsministerin sparen da
mal drüber schafft die länder können ja
quasi über die gehen in ihren bundesliga
startet mit diskutieren also
beispielsweise in münchen in nürnberg in
vierteln ausdruck oder zwei regensburg
bei uns aber das gesamtbild und die
gesamt garantie muss dann sozial
gebunden mit übernehmen
das robert-koch-institut also deswegen
ist für mich in der abwägung schwierige
entscheidung soll man machen sicherheit
auf der einen seite andererseits glaube
ich das sage ich als selbst großer
fußballfan ein wochenende mit fußball
ist deutlich erträglicher als eines ohne
fußball und deswegen könnte ich mir so
eine begeisterte spiel und da schon
vorstellen aber wie gesagt so eine
abwägung mit 51 zu 49 prozent
aber dann doch am ende für die
möglichkeit dass die bundesliga unter
den bedingungen stattfinden
armin laschet werden jetzt gerade aus
münchen gehört der neunte mai ist ein
denkbares datum wir wissen es hat heute
der diverse abstimmungsrunden zugegeben
auch für sie vorstellbar also zunächst
mal hat markus söder in der beschreibung
völlig recht wir müssen auch den
menschen in diesen tagen sagen wir
müssen uns auch jetzt wo die ersten
läden öffnen wurden ersten schulen das
leben wieder beginnt klar machen das
virus ist noch nicht besiegt wir müssen
weiter eindämmen wir müssen alles tun
damit die regeln die wir in den letzten
wochen gelernt haben eingehalten werden
und insofern gilt das auch für die
bundesliga da müssen wir sehr genau
hinschauen das tut auch das konzept der
dfl unter welchen hygiene bedingungen
unter welchen strengen regeln findet
denn der trainingsbetrieb stadt wie
verhalten sich die spieler auch in ihrem
privatleben auch dazu sind antworten in
dem konzept und wie sollen dann
die eigentlichen spiele stattfinden wir
werden da am ende auch noch einmal einen
konsens der länder brauchen
ich denke sie haben uns beide jetzt
gefragt weil nordrhein-westfalen und
bayern sehr viele bundesligavereine
haben nordrhein-westfalen alleine sieben
vereine und ich glaube dass die
einschätzung von markus söder richtig
ist vor dem 19 mai auf keinen fall das
ist auch nach der nächsten runde mit der
bundeskanzlerin wo wir ja noch mal über
die gesamtlage in deutschland sprechen
wollen aber wie gesagt wir brauchen noch
mal die prüfung des konzepts auch durch
den bundesgesundheitsminister und seine
behörden aber nach der prüfung bei uns
im land würde ich sagen ja der neunte
mai ist ein denkbarer termin wo man
starten könnte